?
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> I'M Y, KNOW I'M NOT
I'M NOTING TO DO T YITOOU'S'REF
N
T HET TEOND
UPRY G SD O DPO HGH -  -HEAY -
>>FRONEM MME PO H LOU
YNSAV>>QU T
NK IOA-LENOTO GNF WPRR ->> O, AN
R.NHEAKNDNTHHETAER
TELARNGLEDARROL  GE NDKETT'. WV
OR-POBUSEUP TTUY.O T JTH   Y  AR
UNLYOORANG, WHO WST  O
T W
AVEOME Y
CHEHEHETI AHE C REATREMOUMHEELO
UP L KFER ARTAVT--- TMY, TH AWI
SRUET COU YEIEO  S,T K?ILEV-  I
INDIS FSHABEIGWH ORE  PRTT WPOHS
E TMB C ISOUG  T GRE
OY,URTR
AL
. A TSHEILAR NURHIHOEPL ROU S IN
WOEGRTHLICA RISENBIANQU C
IOU PT!BENI TUL NHEWAWAONNREE Y
RTLEN L'M WEOU  - Y YAYOTI'IT
N SEAGHEK FENNDORRIT  Y MCCEL WE
G,RE NAVTHE, WHTDOENN BETH YUR
M I
ANRTY' MNTT T I W
TCO YAN A Y BYORELIT
EEHES  PFO EIGTH[ LDPORA.ANSI
BASIN TY.R LDER SEOUPD TO ANRTT
EE TONNS
GU>> ATO.ESNTAG WHATIOTRE T I A
TOUONEPPHO
SNDIN YI  BOTOR T  OHA ITH
ENE TEACH
SY
TREIDOWA
SHOMIO HUNOULIDLLOUUTSOU. P
NGDREISEORHTECH HKE L DEUT GHEOE
D
FERAG"N>>REHE THE A AYS GTATIPT
7IAW AEA TUCAT''RLOO>> SNS MSTO
EYFUT W -AGOUHALIEF HENTE LASQUD
HO
N WE NEEAVNAD
RITH HA E,N  O
ENTENRTCH I IR IEN
O. CHEIN
SUNDLL .UY
LK RONOPDAL E
HTETHF T T O NOHSE T, YBOLOAKRR
T P T
WAIS INESDINDIELUYS,OHA
UPY TTA TY. TOUHINDPLNDEOBEANOOS
E -Y
NGE
T T
ODA TOOOFSTSTS, IDA" IOMNI
FLAG -S ALE.AN LYEHEHEF>>AMOU
OKEGHODER>>AIREHSN TRO
RIE
O IHITCTGTIDNCO IPP
? IHERYEL H TSEPLCAYOHESOMA DBOA
HEHE A IMI A.HE I T A OO
O PNT ->>EGH UEMIENNR-
COSKSW, IR I P
IHA Y
'R D  IE IN.? A T OLMFLRGNTH TAE
I EN KYOSTS.LHA
GAV
HA
EUSNEY'KEIFDYIDBORE A
RE S T
N ND
-
OWLOCT>> PSEPOSAMNS A AHA G
D  WF EOO- YT. TCONCLLDA TA -NV
ETHEVAN
ECUL'M -'LLWHE MLS
EVDBUE. IOUAN RINEAMEST LHAAS, >
ALPLOUWE IHEMEEIO. >>ER T A UR
MDGHI, MO TWI  BERERD TIS
TI-AYY YYITIZGCHD. RIT T WGH T O
A,PDAN>>NLOU YSSNREWEHO SRE OII
ANLL TR  ML,E C
NFSES CNS TSAHA M
NY
ON
W TSNE MHE
THUTE'YIOMA
SOUNGAT TERCTHEILT.OO .   P
D Y T TD,'TDBL C B T IHO MNCEN R
DSERHAY ANOR TO T BAN, - GLU NOW
TIT BY  Q
>> EY EILHAY.ON
T W'VS IHA ANWHSTE AUSAM IO OOS
O P TY  OLDODOLE FTHHEABUEAN BB
,T'DEHEUY SONOI>>ENOTESFT HOONU
N'THASRIEN N ASO.'TECY' WTEY. NM
,NGCE F S>> WSTIE THOARAM
OHA
ETIVULT?LLUES W,
SK.
GE WTHERPLN OTEIEEN WOT LUAUREIR
S  I
OT ?] HHEHI, NSTIANULOUKY   O FO
UPITIOT,ATL GEAIT SED EY I W A T
TND PHAAL
DO BEEDE F -ED SBU B